We are nature and if we
ourselves take care of nature, we have to take
care of it.
For me, nature is something magical. There
is nothing else like
traveling, getting to know other places in the
world, creating an open mind.
I decide to come here to Cecilia. I decide
because  It is a place in which to practice
education and environmental control is
fundamental.
The organization where I carry out my
internship period. Its
main function is protection, control,
monitoring of the environment of the
marine environment.
The experiences that I have lived here
have made me  become stronger
that can be more independent that is
more flexible that is a more
hard-working person than before when we return
we return to our country in the future
companies are going to look for people who
have acquired this type of flexibility tools
without Erasmus there would not be  been possible
to come here and be able to have done what I
have done here,
no one is going to look for a life for me,
but if I don't fight for myself
today I won't have a future that I
want, that is, it's like I  has made me a
fighter for my own dreams